bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver émission ce soir
entièrement consacrée au climat pour
l'ouverture de la COP 28 à Dubaï bonsoir
Dominique bour et merci d'avoir accepté
notre d'être notre grand témoin ce soir
vous êtes philosophe l'un des grands
penseurs de l'écologie on va bien sûr
revenir avec vous sur le choix contesté
de de Dubaï en cette année 2023 la plus
chaude qui est jamais connu la planète
vous publiez aussi un dialogue avec
Philippe zawati sur la finance face au
limites planétaires vous nous direz ce
que sont ces limites on en parlera tous
les deux dans la deuxième partie notre
grand débat ce soir et nous qu'est-ce
qu'on fait la COP 28 c'est aussi
l'occasion de s'interroger sur le bilan
de la France contre le réchauffement
climatique beaucoup de réformes beaucoup
de résistance aussi sur le terrain
l'écologie à la française est-elle à la
hauteur Emmanuel Macron est-il un grand
président de la Transition nous en
débattons tout de suite avec mes invités
sur ce plateau enfin nos affranchis ce
soir on retrouve la carte blanche de
Nicole ferrony avec plaisir et puis le
parti prix politique de Yael Goz enfin
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée signée par Elsa mondain Gava
voilà pour le menu on y va Dominique
Bour je suis ça vous regarde ça commence
tout de
[Musique]
suite
c'est son dernier mandat il n'a donc
plus rien à perdre et pourtant est-il
assez ambitieux sur l'écologie alors où
s'ouvre la COP 28 à Dubaï on va
s'interroger ce soir sur le bilan
présidentiel en matière de transition
écologique l'écologie à la française
c'est son expression modèle de
volontarisme ou de prudence pour ne pas
effrayer bonsoir pierre casenuve et
merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance des hautes scènes ancien
rapporteur du projet de loi sur les
énergies renouvelables vous débattez ce
soir avec votre collègue cyiel Chatelin
bonsoir président du groupe écologiste à
l'Assemblée nationale ainsi que Lucile
schmi bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes la
cofondatrice et la vice-présidente du
think tank la fabrique écologique
Dominique Bour il va de soi que vous
êtes entièrement partie prenante à ce
débat on va d'abord planter le décor
l'actif et le passif du président sur le
climat c'est dans le chrono blco qu'on
accueille tout de
suite
bonsoir mon cher Stéphan bakovski
bonsoir Miriam bonsoir toutes et tous je
vous invite à faire la même chose pour
regarder la chronique de Stéphane alors
j'imagine que ce soir tout le monde
n'aura pas le même avis sur le bilan
écologique du président Macron mais il y
a quand même une chose qui devrai tous
nous mettre d'accord c'est que
l'écologie c'est un sujet dont il parle
beaucoup alors est-ce qu'il en fait
assez vous débattrez mais vous savez que
lors de la derière campagne c'était une
priorité pour lui l'écologie il avait
même dit à Marseille mon second mandat
sera écologique ou ne sera pas donc
l'objectif je vous le rappelle si
toutefois vous l'aviez oublié c'est de
réduire de 55 % les émissions de gaz à
effet d'ici 2030 et pour ça le président
compte sur la planification écologique
c'est sa méthode et il nous la présenta
c'était fin septembre sur TF1 il y a un
chemin d'écologie à la française qui est
une écologie de progrès d'abord je veux
dire aux Français et aux
Français on a fait la moitié du chemin
on l'a fait parce que ces C dernières
années on a réduit nos émissions de CO2
deux fois plus qu'on l'avait fait les 5
années d'avant et donc vous le voyez
d'ici à 2030 il nous faut faire l'autre
moitié du chemin simplement il faut
aller deux fois plus vite alors voyez
que le président parle avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme de cette transition
écologique bon cela dit il faut quand
même comprendre que ça va nous demander
de de gros effort on parle de cette
réduction des émissions de CO2 voyez en
32 ans donc depuis 1990 on a réduit de
25 % les émissions de CO2 et donc là on
compte les réduire de 30 %
supplémentaires en 7 ans c'est c'est pas
deux fois plus vite qu'il faut aller
c'est quatre fois plus vite qu'il faut
aller donc pour atteindre cet objectif
c'est donc la planification écologique
qui a été mise en re l'iddée c'est de
coordonner l'action de tous les
ministères pour pouvoir agir bah dans
tous les domaines parce que c'est dans
tous les domaines qu'il faut agir donc
bien sûr priorité au transport plus gros
émetteurs avec des plus de transport en
commun la voiture électrique on sait
bien que pour le logement c'est la
question de la rénovation qui se pose
préserver la biodiversité là un aspect
très important dépolluer les industries
qui polluent le plus il y a 50 sites en
France qui sont vraiment concernés par
ça la question de l'agriculture durable
et bien sûr comme c'est bientôt Noël
faire preuve de sobriété dans la consomm
dans la consommation alors bien sûr les
les avis sur ces positions du président
dans le domaine de colagie sont assez
contrastés on va dire c'est même parfois
un peu caricatural parce que d'un côté
on a Greenpeace qui nous dit le bilan
Macron c'est la catastrophe dans le
domaine de l'écologie et de l'autre on a
le forum économique de Davos enfin Forum
économique mondial qui nous dit que la
France est parmi les 10 pays qui est le
mieux armé pour la transition écologique
et c'est même le seul pays du G20 donc
pays vraiment puissant économiquement
dans cette catégorie alors Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous en doutez il est plutôt
du côté qui se sont du côté de ceux qui
sont très critiques et lui il dit si on
veut vraiment faire cette transition
écologique il ne faut surtout pas
prendre de demimesur on l'écoute
l'écologie qui n'est pas antiapitaliste
n'est pas de écologie je ne comprends
pas comment on peut être écologue et
dire on continue avec le capitalisme le
vice-président du GC lui-même dit
écoutez c'est pas ble c'est un luxe trop
grand le capitalisme pour l'humanité
aujourd'hui alors faut-il rompre avec le
capitalisme pour sauver la planète
examin l'hypothèse pourquoi pas mais il
y a une deuxième question qui se pose
c'est est-ce que nous sommes prêts à
cette rupture parce que les Français
sont un peu sévè avec le président 65 %
d'entre eux trouvent que il n'en fait
pas assez pour l'écologie en revanche
quand on demande aux Français ce qu'ils
sont prêts à faire eux personnellement
comme effort pour l'écologie bah voyez
arrêter de la viande de manger de la
viande c'est non renoncer à sa maison
individuelle non pareil une majorité ne
veut pas en entendre parler quant à
l'idée de payer plus cher des produits
qui seraient fabriqués localement là
encore les Français ne sont pas prêts
euh oui c'est ça le problème c'est
l'acceptabilité comme on dit des mesures
regardez de deux exemples qui se posent
dès maintenant les collectivités
territorial s'inquiète pour le zan zéro
artificialisation nette on va pouvoir
construire moins de logement les maires
eux s'inquiètent pour la Z des feu zoau
de faible émission des voitures qui sont
interdites de rouler dans certaines
certains endroits donc voyez que en fait
cette question là se pose vraiment c'est
est-ce que ça sera accepté est-ce que
les électeurs seront d'accord pour ces
efforts alors l'avantage du président
Macron c'est que les électeurs bon ben
il a pas de souci puisqu'il ne va pas se
représenter une troisième fois est-ce
que pour autant son plan de
planification écologique est à la
hauteur et bien le débat est ouvert et
ben on y va merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation très claire comme chaque
soir Stéphane je vais commencer par un
petit exercice pour vous situer on va se
prêter à un petit jeu mais sans
caricature est-ce que vous vous pouvez
me donner une note de 1 à 10 Lucille
Schmidt pour commencer pour noter
l'action présidentielle de ces six
premières années de mandat alors moi je
je vais pas faire une réponse de
normande mais je vais dire 6 sur 10 pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
dans son premier mandat Emmanuel Macron
a essayé plusieurs fois de prendre en
considération les enjeux écologiques et
bon il y avait Nicolas HULLOT qui était
avec lui mais il y a quand même eu le
renoncement à Notre-Dame des Landes il y
a eu le renoncement à Europa City il y a
eu la convention citoyenne pour le
climat il y a eu un certain nombre de
lois dites lois écologique euh donc il
me semble que les tentatives et les
tâonnements sont là après pourquoi
est-ce que je mets pas plus euh parce
que il y a des choses qui n'ont il n'a
toujours pas comprises la première c'est
que l'écologie vient souvent de la
société elle vient des territoires elle
elle est quelque chose de collectif elle
se partage et par exemple imaginez que
il y a un homme providentiel de
l'écologie ça il a toujours pas compris
donc il nous fait des vidéos il nous
fait euh euh des trucs genre sa pas pour
ma pomme les procès climatiques donc il
se met en scne il n'associe pas assez le
citoyen à la décision je pense qu'il
n'associe pas assez ses adversaires
politiques et que les victoire des mers
verts qui sont aujourd'hui très nombreux
dans les grandes villes de France ont
dit quelque chose sur la
territorialisation je pense qu'il y a
aussi un autre échec c'est d'imaginer
l'écologie populaire on est dans ce
moment de célébration en tout cas
d'anniversaire de discussion autour de
ce que représente le mouvement des
gilets jaunes 5 ans après et cette façon
dont il a parlé d'écologie populaire à
l'époque je me rappelle qu'il y a eu un
débat avec Jean-Luc M un peu lunaire
pour dire c'est moi qui possède qui
possède l'expression de même qu'il y a
eu le débat sur la planification
écologique où Jean-Luc Mélenchon a dit
il m'a quand même voler mes mots oui
donc il y a un sujet sur l'appropriation
par Emmanuel Macron de mots qui viennent
de la gauche mais ensuite le sujet c'est
comment on remplit de contenu ces mots
et comment on met en œuvre une méthode
qui tombe pas du ciel l'écologie ça ne
se pratique pas en tombant du ciel ça
vient des territoires ça se partage avec
la société et un état écologique c'est
un état qui partage le pouvoir avec les
citoyens déjà beaucoup de choses dans
cette note je note plus que la moyenne
je terminerai par vous pierre casneu
c'est moins facile j'en conviens mais
vous pourrez noter aussi cyiel châelin
alors moi je serai beaucoup plus sévère
moi je mettrai deux deux parce que je
vais reprendre vos exemples Hulo
effectivement il était là il est la
seule chose qu'il a faite c'était une
loi sur la question des exploitations
fossiles et en fait cette loi va
s'appliquer tellement tardivement
qu'elle ne me permet pas aujourd'hui
d'interdire les huit nouveaux forages en
Gironde voilà donc on a une loi mais qui
est inefficace alors qu'on voit bien que
l'objectif de diminution des émissions
c'est d'ici 2030 2uxème exemple
convention citoyenne pour le climat
excellent exemple ça vient des citoyens
on a des propositions très fortes elles
ne sont pas appliquées dans leur très
large majorité euh trisème exemple le
charbon très grande promesse on va
sortir du charbon première loi que sur
lequel moi j'ai dû me prononcer la loi
pouvoir d'achat on réouvre euh là ce
contrat charc une fin programmé quand
même en fait la fin elle était elle
était programmée immédiatement et elle a
été réouverte donc en fait c'est
toujours on a toujours une raison est-ce
que vous voyez une différence entre le
premier mandat les premières années et
le le second les grosses lois hein
climat énergie renouvelable nucléaire
Industri arrive enfin elles étaient voté
là là en fait moi je enfin en fait c'est
c'est sans doute votre chroniqueur qui
l'a dit il parle beaucoup il parle
beaucoup il agit peu ça s'appelle du
Green wasing et je vais finir par deux
choses la première c'est l'insuffisance
souligné par le Conseil d'État en mai
2023 qui dit insuffisance des politiques
climatiques mis en place depuis juillet
2021 donc on est vraiment sur les
politiques d'Emmanuel Macron et c'est
l'impréparation c'està-dire que le Haut
Conseil pour le climat fait son rapport
et dit la France n'est pas prête et donc
je pense si la France n'est pas prête ça
mérite au mieux un de alors ou là c'est
sévère et vous Dominique Bour TR aussi
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
premièrement déjà quand l'on pour
reprendre le référentiel là du de la vos
c'est en fait essentiellement le carbone
et donc la la la la France a un parc
nucléaire avec 3/4 de son électricité
qui est produite de façon décarbonée
c'est avant tout ça qu'on met en avant
et en général c'était le cas aussi dans
le l'exposé de du du stphan Stéphan tout
à l'heure en fait si vous voulez on va
regarder les émissions directes sur un
territoire or tous les pays riches
industriel grosso modo la moitié de
l'emprunte carbone du pays est attachée
aux importations et en plus quand on a
l'ambition et c'est une très bonne chose
de vouloir réindustrialiser la France il
y a une partie si vous voulez du carbone
importé qui va revenir à l'intérieur
mais on peut pas nous le reprocher donc
déjà si vous voulez les indicateurs sont
sont sont très mal faits maintenant si
je regarde si vous voulez la le le
président de la République bien pendant
que Nicolas HULLOT qui est pourtant qui
était un ami à l'époque pendant qu'il
était ministre de l'environnment présidé
ça vous vous avez coprisé sa faotation
oui oui tout à fait et puis c'était
quelqu'un qui était proche à l'époque et
bien si vous voulez pas qu'il était
misvir c'est pas aperçu qu'on détricoter
le droit de l'environnement moi je me
souviens à l'été je ne sais plus c'est
peut-être 2019 2020 une très belle
tribune de plusieurs juristes pas du
tout partisans en eux même qui avait
vraiment montré en quoi en détricoter le
droit de l'environnement ensuite quand
il prend la pause sur les normes
environnementales al plus une pause la
loi égal et C on a détricoté certains
aspects du droit de l'environnement
ensuite les deuxièes choses quand il
prend des initiatives intéressantes par
exemple la convention citoyenne pour le
climat bah déjà c'est le fait du
prince
ensuite quand il dit je m'engage à à à
passer ça sans fil c'est pas
constitutionnel le Parlement il est là
simplement en revanche si vous regardez
Chirac de temps de la Charte de
l'environnement à laqu j'avais aussi
participé lui s'était engagé comme un
fou pour faire passer la charte et ça
pas été simple notre ami Emmanuel Macron
s'est absolument pas engagé pour que
l'essentiel des mesures qui étaient
sorties de la convention citoyenne passe
là il nous dit vous l'avez rappelé il
nous dit mon deuxè quena voilà alors
c'est pas évident parce que je voudrais
quand même dire à nos téléspectateurs
qu'on voulait inviter une personnalité
ou un élu de de droite notamment ou un
économiste ça pas pu se faire donc mais
je sais que vous avez les les moyens de
répondre pierre casenu d'abord même même
je c'est vrai que la note le bulletin
est sévère mais qu'est-ce que vous quel
est votre note à vous et surtout
qu'est-ce que vous répondez il y a des
il y a des questions de méthode des
questions d'engagement non tenu des
questions aussi de de droit qu'est-ce
que vous répondez référentiels n'oubliez
pas c'est des référentiels des
indicateurs tout à fait
bien moi quand je donne une note c'est
peut-être mon côté un peu mateux je
regarde d'abord effectivement les
indicateurs ils sont criticables on
prend que la partie cléma aujourd'hui on
a une trajectoire c'est le FED for55
pour arriver à mo-s 55 % d'émissions en
2030 et donc c'est nos émissions
produites en France aujourd'hui ces
émissions ça a été dit dans le dans le
petit jingle qu'on a eu on a doublé si
vous voulez notre baisse d'émission
entre 2017 et 2022 et aujourd'hui
l'objectif c'est de redoubler encore à
nouveau pour atteindre la moin 55 % en
2030 aujourd'hui on est dans les temps
de passage et si vous regardez
l'ensemble des pays de l'OCDE il y a pas
un pays qui l'année dernière a baissé
autant ses émission que la France sur ce
point donc à ce titre là purement
factuel sur nos émissions le bilan du
président de la République est bon ça
Dominique Bour le reconnaît mais il y a
toutes les émissions orté le deuxième
point je pense que c'est extrêmement
important j'ai entendu il communique
beaucoup
effectivement ce sont des critiques qui
qui moi évidemment je je je ne m'y
associe pas le président a fait
énormément pour l'écologie je vais
reprendre tous les points il y a aucun
sujet sur le sujet de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat c'est autre
chose que la charte pour l'environnement
en terme de contrainte ça a été présenté
aussi il y a énormément de choses qui
ont été retranscrites dans la loi clima
et résilience et à l'époque si vous
voulez tout le monde était là mais ça va
pas assez loin Macron et petit bras tout
ce que vous voulez et aujourd'hui quand
on voit que les mesures s'appliquent les
mêmes qui hier disaient que ça va pas
que ça allait pas assez loin sont les
premiers à vouloir freiner et à
expliquer qu'en fait on n' pas mis assez
les moyens donc ce sont les la faible
mission ce sont évidemment euh le le
zéro artification net c'est toutes ces
loislà que on apporte al estce pour pour
avancer pour nous aider est-ce que vous
pourriez euh au fond essayer d'expliquer
la philosophie du président sur
l'écologie parce qu'elle est parfois
difficile à suivre ce et en même temps
il est volontariste on l'a dit sur la
question des industries vertes sur les
investissements il y a des moyens on va
en discuter mais euh en même temps il il
dit j'adore la bagnole et il prononce le
mot de sobriété en même temps il peut
nous amener sur la fin de l'abondance et
on le sent
très prudent sur la contrainte est-ce
que inciter sans contraindre c'est ça le
logiciel du Président je ne crois pas
déjà parce qu'on a fait beaucoup de
choses pour contraindre je veux dire
pour moi l'écologie vous avez trois
options vous avez la contrainte qui peut
être réglementaire qui peut être
législative vous avez l'incitation qui
peut être financière qui peut être
fiscale là aussi et vous avez la
pédagogie globalement c'est les trois
armes que que le législateur et que le
pouvoir public a en ses mains pour selon
les sujets on arrive à contraindre
aujourd'hui on a entendu eu des débats
même au sein de la majorité de personnes
sur une contrainte très particulière qui
est la sortie du parc locatif des
passassoirs thermiques on a mis une
contrainte très forte qui est que on ne
pourra plus louer ces cont location 2025
le zéro artificialation net c'est de la
contrainte on ne pourra plus
artificialiser les sol d'ici à 2050 avec
un point d'étape extrêmement fort d'ici
2030 ce sont des contraintes très fortes
le président à la main for tiendrez vous
tiendrez c'est intéressant vous vous les
citez on les a d'ailleurs listé sur un
panneau c'est C trois lieu de résistance
l'artificialisation les zones à faible
émission pour les voitures les passoir
thermiques vous tiendrez parce que on
entend y compris au sein de la majorité
des voies s'éleves Édouard Philippe
Bruno le ma pour dire basta pour dire ça
va trop loin trop vite et c'est là où je
vais revenir juste sur la philosophie et
la stratégie du président de la
République il y a déjà une partie
planification ça a été redit moi j'ai
pas de il m' dire que c'est un thème de
gauche et Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'a
parilleurs beaucoup repris les
écologistes aussi moi je je me réjouis
juste de voir que le président en a fait
son axe de travail et sa méthodologie
aussi parce que c'est la bonne et ça
j'ai aucun doute là-dessus cette
planification elle s'incarne à la fois
dans le gouvernement avec une Premier
ministre qui en est directement en
charge un secrétariat général à la PL
finification et deux ministres de
tutelle un sur l'écologie et un sur
l'énergieage par totalement inédit le
travail ve dire que toutes les
politiques publiques aujourd'hui sont
passé au crible cl absolument dingue on
n'a jamais eu un niveau de granularité
on pourra après débattre sur ce qu'on va
faire mais en terme de granularité déjà
sur le constat sur tout le travail qui
est réalisé de de de de cartographie de
nos émissions et de trajectoires
derrière associé c'est absolument unique
et ensuite vous l'avez dit l'enjeu c'est
de convaincre et d'embarquer un maximum
de França der ça d'embarquer la société
civile je l'ai vu sur les derniers je
commande sur les derniers camambber moi
je le dis toujours c'est beaucoup plus
utile pour le climat d'avoir 95 % des
Français qui diminuent leur consommation
de bœuf que d'avoir 5 % de véan à Paris
ça ne sert à rien oui donc on retrouve
ce que dans votre discours embarqué
massivement ça donne cette phrase que
j'ai retrouvé prononcé au salon du
Bourget oou lui demander s'il fallait
arrêter de prendre l'avion il dit la
sobriété bien organisée non punitive
raisonnable et bonne celle qui consiste
à dire qu'il faut renoncer à la
croissance je ne la crois pas
raisonnable dixit Emmanuel Macron on a
on a on comprend où il veut aller Lucile
Schmidt avec des outils c'est quand même
ce gouvernement qui prononce ses deux
mots pour la première fois qu'il est met
en acte planification adaptation ça
c'est quand même assez nouveau avec des
moyens dans chaque secteur et des
objectifs de calendrier al il y a
plusieurs choses d'abord c'est un
gouvernement qui est obligé euh de
prononcer ces mots parce que il y a un
principe de réalité qui sont les
dérèglements climatiques et l'extinction
de la biodiversité donc ce qu'on peut
dire effectivement c'est que depuis
qu'Emmanuel Macron a été élu il vit un
moment écologique qui le veuilleent ou
non et nous le vivons tous c'est-à-dire
que il le vit comme nous la deuxième
chose qui me semble importante
j'écoutais pierre casneu qui disait au
fond on a trois trois axes possibles
pour la l'action publique je pense que
vous en avez oublié un qui est aussi la
transformation de soi et le logiciel qu'
porte donc le sujet c'est tout de même
pourquoi est-ce que la croissance
pourquoi est-ce que la consommation par
exemple ce qui vient de se passer autour
d'une campagne de l'ADEM qui promouvait
la dévente c'està dire au fond une forme
de décroissance lorsqu'il s'agit de
consommer a créé une sorte de malaise au
sein du gouvernement entre le ministre
de l'économie et le ministre de
l'écologie comme si au fond ce
gouvernement ne savait pas très bien
comment il traitait lui-même cette
question la sobriété qu'il a mis à
l'ordre du jour lorsqu'il s'agit de
faire des économies de coût au fond on
est dans quelque chose de différent en
terme de projet de société et de projet
de gouvernement ça me semble être un
point essentiel après qu'Emmanuel Macron
tatonne moi je lui mets 6 je répète et
j'assume d'ailleurs vous lui mettez
combien d'AM on pas
endu je vais vous dire par que allez
rapidement pour continuer à débattre je
vais lui mettre la note de 8 sur ce qui
a été fait parce que justement pour moi
il est dans les temps de passage et il y
a vraiment une volonté très forte d'
aller mais je lu mets que V et je mets
mettrai pas 10 alors que je suis le plus
macroniste de tous les macronist j'ai
été son chef de cabineturais pu mettre
10 mais parce que je suis aussi un jeune
de 28 ans et je considère que ce qu'on
fait sur l'écologie ça va pas assez loin
et je le dis il y a aucun problème et je
l'ai déjà dit au président intéressant
c'est qu'à vous entendre tous il a
presque la moyenne
oui donc parce que comme l' dit comme
disais il y a aujourd'hui des voix même
au sein de la majorité qui veulent
ralentir qui veulent pas aller assez
loin et c'est mon rôle moi en tant que
jeune député de tirer un maximum
laaccord pour continuer aller plus loin
dans
l'ambitionblementierre est très jeune
euh mais euh bon étant étant plus âgé je
vais dire un certain nombre de choses
aussi c'est que moi je pense que Macron
a été bon sur l'Europe c'est-à-dire que
par exemple le pacte vert européen dans
son premier mandat il a il l'a porté
plus voliste à l'extérieur à
l'innational Europe aujourd'hui il est
tenté à mon avis par une sorte même sur
ce qu'il a fait auparavant une sorte de
tête à queue c'està-dire que la question
de faire la pause sur le pacte vert elle
est posée pour les élections européenne
comment ça va se passer parce que la
droite et l'extrême droite au fond
promeuve le climatooscepticisme et donc
tout sujet c'est quand on fait de
mandats de pas être d'ailleurs comme
Nicolas Sarkozi l'était très écologiste
au début il a fait qu'un mandat hein
mais ensuite beaucoup moins écologiste
et terminant par l'écologie ça commence
à bien faire attention au tête à queue
et donc il commence à 6 pour moi il faut
qu'il fasse attention en fin de mandat à
ne pas être à 3 et demi h s Chatelin je
voudrais quand même vous soumettre cette
question de la la technolution parce
qu'on entend beaucoup autour de Emmanuel
Macron dans les projets de loi ça se
traduit très très concrètement dire
qu'au fond la technique c'est la
solution au défis climatiques est-ce que
pour vous ça ne suffira pas est-ce que
vous mettez derrière le mot de sobriété
comment dire une baisse de la production
une baisse de la consommation jusqu'à
l'arrêt complet d'activité la
décroissance la question est pas de
savoir est-ce que pour nous la
technologie est une solution la question
est de savoir ce que nous disent les
scientifiques aujourd'hui ce que dit le
G c'est que ça ne suffit pas donc c'est
l'une des solutions oui c'est une des
solutions parmi d'autres la première
c'est effectivement d'avoir un mode de
consommation son moindre la deuxième
préserver notre habitat naturel nous
venons d'avoir le débat sur les
mégamacines en fait si on veut de l'eau
et ben en fait il faut effectivement ne
pas artificialiser et c'est pour ça que
les écologistes ont été très fortement
en opposition au texte du du Sénat qui
venait détricoter leusanne et où je
pense a permis pour le coup le en même
temps c'est-à-dire que s'il y a pas de
voie écologiste forte et ben en fait on
assiste à des renoncements renoncement
au niveau européen mais moi je vais
revenir sur la question de la
trajectoire dit finalement pour poser
une note il faut voir est-ce que la
trajectoire est tenue moi ma question
c'est est-ce que la trajectoire est du à
l'action d'Emmanuel Macron et de ce
gouvernement la réponse est donnée par
le Conseil d'État elle dit la baisse des
émissions de CO2 constatée en 2022 n'est
pas le résultat de mesure spécifiqu et
structurell elle est les résultat
d'événement conjoncturel et de la
combinaison de deux choses la hausse des
prix et l'hiver doux et donc en fait oui
nous sommes dans les clous mais
malheureusement pas parce que nous avons
un gouvernement qui qui a été volontaire
et donc je voudrais finir quand même sur
la question de la la
technosolutionnisme on a notamment on
part sur les avions on rêve d'un monde
où on va voir des avion sans CO2 cette
idée d'carburant fait à base
d'hydrogène si toute la flotte française
devait fonctionner avec ce icarburant on
sera à peu près à 10 pr donc en fait la
question aujourd'hui est-ce queou il y a
l'avion pour qui ça prend du temps mais
on peut parler des des énergies
renouvelable de la question question
vous me posiez et c'était est-ce que
aujourd'hui le le mode de vie est souten
la réponse est non est-ce que par contre
changer nos votes de vie va emener un
mal-être plus grand je pense que la
réponse est non aussi c'estàdire qu'on
peut avoir un mode de vie où on a plus
de temps où on a plus de sérénité où on
n'est pas dans l'angoisse aujourd'hui on
a un système de l'angoisse et donc je
pense qu'il faut en sortir et ça on peut
le faire si on est dans une idée en fait
de de de sortir mais là pour le coup
jeendrai encore des mots sans acte
c'estàd d'un système de l'abondance et
de la surconsommation et de la
surproduction la question n pas d'être
dans une décroissance
finalement donc la question du
changement de modèle pour éviter la fin
de nos écosystèmes c'est évident
Dominique Bour je vous donne la parole
tout de suite mais j'essaie quand même
de rééquilibrer un peu des choses il y a
quand même des moyens qui sont mis parce
que tout ça ne peut pas marcher sans
sans mettre des milliards sur la table
jean-pisaniferie par d'un mur
d'investissement 67 milliards par an
d'ici 2030 on en a pas les moyens il y a
qu'à regarder le budget mais quand même
on est cette année 2024 à 40 milliards
pour la transition c'est pas rien ça
vous le reconnaissez oui oui bien sûr
mais si vous voulez comment dire faut
bien faire le départ entre le diagnostic
et on va voir le problème est très
difficile et puis les solutions qu'on
veut bien y apporter le le le diagnostic
il est faux si vous ne regardez que le
carbone et c'est la raison pour laquelle
quand le GC a été créé et Madame tcher
et Monsieur ran ont insist pour que cet
organisme ne concerne que le climat de
telle sorte qu'il n'y ait que le carbone
par parce que là on pouvait penser et
c'est même pas le cas c'était rappelé
tout à l'heure qu'on pouvait répondre
par des technologies par des
technologies seules si vous regardez un
référentiel plus large si vous regardez
par exemple ce qu'on appelle les limites
planétaires j'espère voilà d'expliquer
un petit peu ça ben là je suis vraiment
désolé parce que si vous voulez c'est la
croissance en elle-même qui est
destructrice qu'est-ce qui se passe avec
les limites planétaires par c'est que
l'humanité prend beaucoup trop de place
elle elle elle amplifie des flux et elle
amplifie des flux parce que son le
volume de ces activités économiques est
trop important et puis
accumule des molécules différentes on on
on y reviendra et donc et si vous
regardez par exemple la question de la
biodiversité la destruction de la
biodiversité elle est très directement
corrélée au niveau de nos activités à la
croissance du PIB donc si vous regardez
la chose de façon scientifique neutre
non politique il y a une contradiction
majeure entre notre type de civilisation
nos modes de vie est ce qu'il
conviendrait de faire et si vous
regardez là jeev VI 30 secondes au
climat si vous voyez ce qui est en train
de se passer cette année c'est
bougrement inquiétant je je
renvoie la tribune qu'on a publié mais
al endez après effectivement
politiquement franchement c'est pas
simple je vous dis pas que c'est ah bah
je regardais alors pierre casneu parce
que il faut quand même rappeler qu'il y
a voilà les ONG il y a les oppositions
qui font pression puis il y a les
acteurs qu'il soi au niveau national ou
au niveau local les
moyens est-ce qu'ils sont vraiment
suffisants quand vous voyez pan ferie
qui a fait le programme économique
d'Emmanuel Macron considérer que ça ça
n'est pas à la hauteur pour être tout à
fait précis le pisaniferie mafus si Tom
bien les deux on le match cette année on
est on est cohérent avec le Pisani
mafous cette année avec le la hausse des
7 milliards dans les déclarations il
nous manque toujours 700 millions sur la
rénovation thermique aujourd'hui le
compte n'est pas totalement bon le
budget s manque que 700 millions on aura
déjà donc est extraordinaire je dire
c'est le première fois on a une Haos de
7 milliards de budget c'est évidemment 7
milliards par rapport à 2023 ça fait 40
milliards pour la transition exactement
c'est gigantesque mais dans le Pisan ma
F ça représente pas seulement la dépense
de l'État c'est aussi des collectivités
territoriales c'est aussi les
entreprises la mobilisation de l'épargne
enfin c'est un budget complet entre
guillemets donc évidemment un effort de
l'État massif mais on a entendu parler
et on avait c'était tout à fait juste
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui la la
transition écologique ça doit pénétrer
les territoires parce que ce sont là les
acteurs de terrain que ce soit les
entreprises que ce soit évidemment les
collectivités territoriale et là il y a
un travail massif à faire pour embarquer
les collectivités territoriales et les
acteurs de terrain dans ce sujetl c'est
ce qui se passe avec les fameuses COP
décentralisé donc c'est comment on fait
pour que la planification donc les
magnifiques graphiques d'Antoine payon
et tout le travail qui est réalisé avec
le sgpe on le décentralise au niveau de
chénificationcolog je dis Antoine payant
comme ça le téléspectateur pouvait s
racrocher et donc ça c'est ce qui est
lancé dans les trois dernières semaines
partout dans chacune des régions en
France et et et bien sûr en areem
également euh donc on a ce sujetl et
puis ensuite c'est aussi comment on
change de modèle on a beaucoup parler de
climat peu de biodiversité et très peu
de d'énergie sur le sujetnerg oui mais
sur le sujet du financement il y a des
choses qu'on fait qui la payera ben une
partie évidemment l'État c'est
l'engagement qu'on met on a déposé des
amendements assez puissant aussi pour la
première fois dans le PLF sur la dette
verte j'en profite d'être sur votre
plateau pour en parler on a travaillé
sur ce ce sujet- là parce qu'aujourd'hui
les collectivités territoriales peuvent
s'endetter elles ont les moyens de le
faire sauf qu'aujourd'hui un bon maire
c'est un maire qui s'endettete pas parce
que c'est géré en bon paère de famille
or on a besoin face à ce mur
d'investissement qui est devant nous
c'est
aussi l'idée à un moment donné de sortir
effectivement les investissements dans
la transition énergétique dans la
rénovation des bâtiments dans cette but
là de de de de réduction de notre
empreinte carbone de sortir ces
investissements là de la dette générale
par la bonne dette verte et puis la et
bien sûr et ça je pense que c'est un
mécanisme vers lequel on va tendre de
plus en plus c'est extrêmement important
parce que la fin dette climatique et
dette financière vont être parfaitement
fongibles il nous reste une poignée de
minute à peine je voudrais quand même
qu'on termine sur un fait d'actualité
vous montrer ce ce sujet de Marion
Becker parce que c'est en cette journée
d'ouverture de la COP 28 que la France a
été choisie pour les Jos d'ivers bonne
ou mauvaise idée explication Marion
Becker et vous réagissez juste
après une candidature
Express annoncé en juillet après avoir
obtenu l'accord de l'Élysée officialisé
début novembre et validé hier par le
Comité international olympique après
l'élimination des deux autres candidats
la Suisse et la Suède la France est
quasi certaine d'organiser les Jeux
olympiques d'hiver en 2030 il y a une
excellente base il faut reconnaître la
capacité de la France à organiser des
des événements dans tous les sports
divers intervalle régulier il faut
mettre tout ça en musique Emmanuel
Macron s'en est immédiatement félicité
promettant des jeux innovants et durable
c'est l'un des atouts de la candidature
de la France 95 % des sites existent
déjà comme le trempelin de sois ski créé
pour les Jeux Olympiques d'Alberville en
1992 les régions auverneuronalpe et
provencealpe Côte d'Azur accueilleront
les compétitions réparties sur quatre
zones seulle une patinoire reste à
construire à Nice le clan français dont
Martin Fourcade ancien champion de
biathlon l'assure ce seront des jeux
sobre et responsable les Alpes
françaises 2030 seront un modèle dans
celui des Jeux olympiques de d'hiver
donc je suis je suis très heureux de
leur côté des associations écologistes
alertent sur l'impact de ces Jeux
Olympiques ils dénoncent une candidature
à contesens alors que le réchauffement
climatique touche particulièrement la
montagne et que la neige disparaît de
nos massifs que l'avenir des stations de
ski est incertain des arguments balayés
par les organisateurs déjà les jeux vont
se dérouler en février et en février on
aura de la neige et donc faut faut
vraiment faire attention de de de se
dire que il n'y aura plus de neige en
2030 ça n'est pas vrai la France sera
officiellement désignée en juillet
prochain juste avant le coup d'envoi des
Jeux olympiques de Paris restera une
inconnue la présence de neige
naturelle allez on s'en réjouit on s'en
désole ou pas de cette décision des gos
divers dans nos Alpes sch moi moi ce que
je trouve c'est que on n'arrive toujours
pas à penser la nature en fait quand on
est au sein de l'État quand on est en
politique c'est-à-dire que cette
question cette affirmation comme quoi il
y aura forcément de la neige en fait on
n sait rien c'està-dire que la nature se
rappelle à nous quand même dans son
caractère imprévisible je rappelle qu'il
y a une multiplication de catastrophes
naturelles je rappelle que qui sont
créés en fait par l'activité humaine
donc on est dans cette situation d' donc
vous regrettez ce choix je regrette et
en tout cas par rapport pp à votre
question tout à l'heure sur la
technologie je pense qu'il a là-dedans
une conception de l'idée qu'on peut tout
faire et que l'humanité est toute
puissante contre laquelle je m'élève
très rapidement serriel Chatelin bah moi
en tant que député de liser je trouve
que c'est une catastrophe c'est une
catastrophe parce qu'en fait on risque
potentiellement de voir des méga
bassines des neige comm on a voulu le
faire à la clusa pour absolument avoir
de la neige qu'on est dans un espèce de
dénis qu'on peut continuer comme ça sur
des choses gigantesque et quand même on
a gagné faute de faute de concurrents
enfin il faut le dire en fait c'est vrai
il y a plus grand monde qui n' qui en
veut donc fa réfléchir et et le mot de
la fin pierre CEN je m'en réjouis pour
l'esprit de l'mpisme et pour la France
je trouve que c'est formidable qu'on
puisse accueillir une compétition par
ailleurs 2030 effectivement on sa pas
siura de la neige en février on espère
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il y en aura
plus en 2060 c'est ça le vrai sujet et
donc et peut-être même avant par que
c'est peut-être le prochain round j'ai
fait le calcul rapidement entre entre
Alberville et et ici une dernière fois
et puis après c'est ça oui non mais
exactement et donc je pense que le sujet
qui doit nous inquiéter c'est celui-ci
et et donc c'est quoi c'est tout cramé
on attend et mais je suis pas sûr que
d'avoir des Jeux Olympiques contribuent
à l'exension de la
neige on s'arrête là on voulait vous
faire réagir sur ce dernier mais sujet
d'aualité merci cétait c'était
passionnant c'était passionnant de de
vous entendre et c'était pas évident
parce que vous étiez en minorité mais
vous êtes bien défendu pierreen merci à
vous merci d'être venu débattre on
s'arrête là vous restez avec moi
Dominique Bour dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir va nous par l'état
indigne de nos prisons qui vaut
d'ailleurs à la France une condamnation
hier la carte blanche de Nicole feroni
on retrouve avec joie et puis de quoi
nous parlez-vous Elsa dans Bourbon
Express ce soir je vais vous raconter
comment les insoumis sont passés à un
cheveu de faire passer une proposition
de loi un cheveu à l'Assemblée c'est six
voix à peu près à tout de suite les amis
mais d'abord Dominique Bour on va parler
des enjeux de cette COP 28 qui s'est
ouverte à Dubaï aujourd'hui 197 états
réunis pendant 2 semaines pour tenter de
se mettre d'accord sur la réduction des
des énergies fossiles tout cela aux
Émirats arabunis l'un des principaux
pétroliers de la planète est-ce bien
raisonnable vous nous le dites juste
après votre portrait signé els
mondingava si on vous invite Dominique
Bour c'est pour savoir s'il n'est pas
déjà trop
tard vraiment là on est en train de
détruire les conditions d'habitabilité
de la planète un constat qui donne le
vertige et nous c'est d'angoisse mais
vous n'êtes pas complètement pessimiste
vous recherchez des solutions Dominique
Bour vous êtes philosophe professeur
honoraire à l'Université de Lausanne
vous avez publié entre autres le marché
contre l'humanité chaque geste compte et
aujourd'hui la finance face aux limites
planétaires alors regardons un conceptte
cher au philosophe que vous êtes celui
de la radicalité pour vous il faut
changer radicalement nos modes de vie
vie produire moins consommer moins vous
êtes favorable par exemple à des quotas
de consommation mais comment les faire
accepter quand certains refusent toute
forme d'écologie
punitive si on se contient pas comment
voulez-vous y arriver donc quand vous
dites écologie punitive ça veut dire que
se contenir ça veut dire réduire un
certain nombre de consommation ce qui
détruit l'habitabilité de la terre c'est
ça l'enjeu du climat sur la finance à
présent dans votre dernier livre tiré
d'une conférence avec le finan phipti
vous considérez la finance comme
nécessaire vous mettez en avant un
paradoxe il faut produire moins certes
mais l'investissement pour changer notre
système et adapter notre planète est
énorme alors pour vous finance et
sobriété ne sont pas incompatibles et en
parlant d'incompatibilité Dominique Bour
nous avons une question une COP en plein
pays de l'or
noir n'est-ce pas un peu le début de la
fin réponse oui de certaine manière en
Joan rockstrum qui est le le le
scientifique à l'origine des limites
planétaires a dit écoutez on n' pas
besoin de Cop il suffit simplement de de
prendre des politiques publiques en
harmonie avec le diagnostic donc il
faudrait la boycotter comme certaines
ONG ou c'est abdiqué d'un espace quand
même de négociation on va quand même à
tout seigneur toutur il y a un premier
résultat qui est pas inintéressant c'est
sur les pertes et dommages avec toute la
difficulté parce que si vous voulez les
pertes et dommages la solidarité entre
oui ça c'est très important mais imp
pays PV par pas capable de les calculer
c'estàdire que on n pas compris ce qui
se passait avec le dérèglement
climatique je je je vous rappelle que là
c'est la première année on est un peu
plus d'un 5 cette année vous avez moin
60% 65 % de rendement céréalier en
Espagne 50 % pour le rendement viticole
euh en en en Grèce et pourquoi tout ça
mais bien sûr et pourquoi tout ça bah
parce que on est plus dans les années
2000 à 2010 désormais on a des vagues de
chaleur récurrentes partout c'est quoi
d'ailleurs ces canicules qui durent et
bien c'est que justement on a changé
complètement de régime climatique le
fait qu'on a des vagues de chaleur
permanentes et compris en hiver he vous
savez qu'on a eu deux journées là il y a
quelques jours on était à plus de 22 en
2030 pour revenir au sujet précédent en
2030 la moyenne sur 10 ans sera 1 der5
passer d'un der5 à 2°gr et c'est déjà
dans les tuyaux c'est doubler tous les
événements extrêmes alors écoutez on est
sérieux ce qui se passe à à à Dubaï
n'est absolument pas proportionné au
diagnostic scientifique qui est lui très
solide à la différence de ses décisions
donc ça veut dire que pour vous les cops
sont déjà dépassés il faudra trouver
d'autres alternatives d'autres lieux de
décision M non c'est pas simplement
qu'elles sont dépassées mais ça a été
montré elles sont dans un univers qui
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec la
réalité on continue à parler d'unsinger
je vous a dit cette année c'est un peu
plus d'unsinger et sultan Ahmed aljabber
le ministre de l'Industrie patron de la
compagnie émirati du pétrole pas digne
du tout de confiance pour convaincre
après tout ceux qu'il connaî le mieux
les pétroliers oui alors en plus il
s'est fait prendre la main dans le sac
il a dit lui-même qu'il allait profiter
de son rôle dans la C pour négocier
nouveau contrat prétolier donc écoute
c'est une enquête de la BBC on arrête là
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire les
limites planétaires précisément c'est un
concept qui est peu connu du grand
public il y en a neuf et se c'est ça
sont déjà alors six si si sont déjà si
vous voulez dépassés mais alors vraiment
franchement et puis la 7è est sur le
point d'être dépassé il y en a une sur
la couche d'zone ça all est beaucoup
mieux ça repart un peu dans le mauvais
sens et celle qui est qui est pas
dépassée c'est tout simplement qu'elle a
des effets sur les aérosols elle a des
effets locaux qui sont très importants
modification des moussons réduction de
la photosynthèse mais locaux plutôt dans
le le le sud politique si vous voulez et
alors c'est ces limites c'est simplement
les indicateurs du de la sortie de c'est
l'olocè ça a duré 11700 ans si on fait
commencer l'anthropocè c'est l'époque
géologique dans laquelle on est qui est
marqué par nos activités nous sommes la
principale force géophysiologique sur
cette terre et donc si si on veut bien
comprendre ça c'est les indicateurs qui
nous font sortir de la période de
sécurité qu'on a connu qui a permis le
développement des grandes civilisations
et on est en train de la referm est-ce
qu'on veut pas comprendre et c'est très
difficile à comprendre et très difficile
à admettre si vous voulez nous autres
modernes on s'est imaginé que la nature
était un décor qu'on pouvait y faire ce
qu'on voulait pas non on a découvert que
c'était des écosystèmes et quand on agit
sur tel point ça va avoir plein d'effet
en chaîne qu'on n pas capable de
connaître à l'avance et là ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est en train de
détruire l' l'habitabilité de cette
planète vous dites on sait aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est déjà une forme de
victoire d'être sorti du dénis de
discuter du comment du qui va payer et
non plus de l'existence même des
phénomènes puissiezvous
puissez-vous avoir raison il y a
beaucoup de sondages qui nous montrent
que le le le fait que les problèmes
deviennent concrets ça et on peut
comprendre c'est les l'esprit humain est
assez bizarrement fait bien en fait ça
engendre un déniis et si vous regardez
il y a une très belle étude avec Daniel
bois qui qui qui date de quelques mois
qui a été fait sur 10 pays au au au
monde je crois je sais plus si c'est 10
ou 30 vraiment désolé mais en gros on a
3 tiers de de la population on a un
tiers qui déniit dit non les êtres
humains N sont pour rien les autres vous
disent bah il y a bien des règlements
clatique mais al les premiers ni a un
des règlement les autres vous disent il
y a bien de règlement l'autre l'autre
parti mais mais on y est pour pas
grandchose et donc il y a vraiment un
gros
tiers voilà il y a un énorme chemin qui
dit oui on y est pour quelque chose mais
attendez ne nous demandez pas trop alors
vous qui prenait la réduction du volume
de de toutes nos économies sans
forcément être décroissant la baisse de
la production la baisse de la
consommation dans ce livre vous faites
un dialogue avec un financier Philipp
Dati fondateur de merova qui est un fond
d' investissement vert qui fait partie
de la grande banque natic 6 vous dites
les les défis écologiques ont aussi
besoin de capitaux privés est-ce que la
finance privée on sait que ce sont des
milliards peut jouer un rôle important
dans la préservation de la planète elle
devrait elle ne le joue pas c'est
vraiment si vous voulez la finance
vraiment durable parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de greenwhing c'est c'est
peanuts à l'échelle internationale c'est
peanuts et on vous savez très bien on
est dans une époque si vous voulez où
vous avez une explosion des inégalités
c'est vous avez des masses
financière
gigantesque mais approprié par 1 % au
mieux de la population donc on est face
à à à ce défi est ce qui avait l'intérêt
de ce livre c'est que j'avais en face de
moi quelqu'un totalement h en plus très
bien formé qui bah oui lui il accepte le
diagnostic c'est quelqu'un qui a une
formation scientifique il y a aucun
problème sur le diagnostic alors après
entre le diagnostic qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire en matière de finances qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire en matière de politique
alors franchement c'est pas simple et je
suis le premier à le dire moi ce que je
reproche aux politiques c'est de ne pas
faire partager le diagnostic à la
population et c'est l'essentiel reproche
que je fais un notre président mais je
pourrais le faire à beaucoup d'autres
person vous pensez que s'il était
partagé alors l'acceptabilité serait au
rendez-vous vraiment fin du monde
deviendrait plus je suis pas face ce
point là mais si vous voulez ça la
première condition à ce que le
diagnostic soit partagé c'est au moins
qu'il soit énoncé et qu'il soit énoncé
non pas par les experts qui n'ont aucune
main sur les manettes mais par les gens
qui ont les mains sur les manettes et
c'est ça que j'ai appréciéon dialogue
avec ce financier c'est que lui il a des
manettes mais il accepte le diagnostic
vous défendez aussi une forme de
radicalité dans l'engagement pour la
planète qu'est-ce que ça signifie
précisément cette radicalité est-ce que
cette cause justifie pour vous une forme
de violence ah non surtout pas non la
radicalité en question c'est c'est une
radicalité du savoir et la prise de
conscience c'est-à-dire que la première
condition je je m'informe je vois où on
en est par exemple effectivement le
référentiel des limites planétaires ben
non je suis désolé c'est quand même de
la décroissance c'est la décroissance
des flux c'est les fameux polymères par
exemple si vous voulez les plastiques
qui envahissent les océans et cetera bah
nous nous AES humains on sait accrocher
des molécules les unes aux autres ça
donne des macrolécules la nature elle
sait qu'en fait alors la radicalité que
vous avancec c'est quoi une forme r
désobéissance civile
parfois la première radicalité c'est
même pas une ricalité c'est simplement
j'ai un constat j'essaie de le
comprendre une fois que je l'ai compris
je le partage et là on aurait besoin des
décideurs même si les décisions à
prendre en fonction de ce constat elles
sont terribles elles sont très très
difficiles et vous allez pas du jour au
lendemain changer une civilisation ça
n'a pas de sens vous voyez où je emmener
les soulèvements de la Terre ce qu'on a
pu être comparé à des à des échos
terroristes hein par par certains
politiques vous avez vu que la
dissolution n'a pas été bien sûr
par là je vous arrête juste sur ce plan
là parler d'écoterrorisme est ridicule
un écoterroriste ça serait quelqu'un qui
voudrait faire changer la population en
la
terrorisant est-ce que c'est le cas
qu'est-ce que vous dites c'est ma
dernière question à un jeune éch anxieux
qui nous regarde ah alors ça c'est très
difficile en tant en tant que professeur
d'université j'étis sans cesse confronté
à ça que quel est le si vous voulez quel
est le le le le où mettre le curseur
parce que l'écoanxiété c'est pas une
maladie individuelle c'est notre société
qui est malade donc reprocher à
quelqu'un d'être écoanxieux c'est
simplement lui reprocher d'être lucide
ce qui est idiot ensuite après quand on
a cette échanxiété comment on vit avec
pour la transformer par l'action par la
militance par le savoir par l'amitié par
le fait de de savoir agir avec d'autres
et créer du sens avec d'autres c'est la
seule réponse qu'on est à l'éco anxiété
merci beaucoup Dominique Bour je
conseille ce petit livre absolument
stimulant la finance face aux limites
planétaires c'est un dialogue entre un
financier Philippe zawati qui a
participé d'ailleurs au programme
écologique d'Emmanuel Macron et
vous-même c'est-à-dire chez Acte Sud
vous restez avec moi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
partie pris il vous vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite yel Go de
France interre éditorialiste politique
dans cette émission et Nicole Ferroni de
passage à Paris B et ben quand elle est
pas marseillaise elle vient sur LCP
exactement une espèce de de ligue
reconstitué franç
allez on commence avec Bourbon Express
comme chaque soir l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée c'est Elsa mondingava qui
nous la raconte ce soir bonsoir Elsa
bonsoir je vais vous raconter l'histoire
d'une majorité qui s'est fait peur ou
des insoumis qui ont presque gagné ça
dépend de quel camp on se place
aujourd'hui c'était la journée
d'initiative du groupe donc de la France
insoumise manuel bonpard propose une loi
pour créer un prix planché sur les
matières premières encadrer les marges
des distributeurs bref lutter contre
l'inflation et au début bah ça se passe
plutôt très bien pour les insoumis
plusieurs de leurs amendements leurs
articles sont adoptés ça sourit ça
applaudit sur les bands des insoumis
puisque parfois ça se joue vraiment à
quelques voix près faut les comprendre
les insoumis c'est pas tous les jours he
qu'ils arrivent à faire adopter leur
propositions pourquoi c'était plus
facile aujourd'hui bien c'est que en
plus des voies de l'anupes ils ont pu
compter sur celle du rassemblement
national le RN qui a voté plusieurs de
leurs amendements et ça la majorité n'a
pas manqué de le déplorer une
proposition pour un nouveau nom vous
appelez la nupen la nouvelle union
populiste écologiste et national comme
ça là vous allez pouvoir plutôt avoir
une certaine forme de cohérence voilà le
bon mot pierre casen qui était sur votre
plateau il y a quelques instants bah
toujours est-il que la majorité à ce
moment-là elle est minoritaire et donc
avant le début le retour de la séance à
15h c'est un manuel bonpard plutôt
confiant qu'on retrouve celle des quatre
colonnes vous vous attendiez bah c'est
une bonne nouvelle en tout cas ça c'est
sûr est-ce que ça m'étonne je pense que
le sujet est tellement présent dans dans
le pays aujourd'hui qu'il est quand même
difficile de s'y opposer donc j'espère
que ça va continuer cet après-midi et
pourtant non ça n'a pas continué ça
s'est corsé pour les insoumis exactement
la majorité bah elle a mis en place
quelques techniques assez classiques
hein quand on ne veut pas perdre en
séance et bien les sous-amendements se
sont multipliés de longues prises de
parole on demande des rapports c'est le
député Alexis hizar par exemple qui s'y
est collé pour la majorité et puis en
coulisse c'est des équipes du groupe
Renaissance qui appellent qui essayent
de rameter tous les députés présents à
l'assemblée on les voit donc ces députés
celle des qu colonne qui arrivent au pas
de course pour VO dansc on rappelle ai
tous les députés qui sont en commission
des LO sur Lejet de lo immigration moi
je discute même avec un député il y a
quelqu'un de l'équipe qui tire man
military pour aller dans l'hémicycle
coup stress il manque une voix ça y est
un député passe la majorité est soulagé
le résultat est très serré mais elle n'a
pas perdu majorité 166 pour 162 contre
168 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
adopté voil la majorité soul tout sour
et puis elle assume cette stratégie dans
les coulisses de l'Assemblée nationale
comme si on y était merci beaucoup Elsa
il manque quelque chose je le petit mot
de la majorité si ça vous va qui assume
justement cette stratégie c'est le jeu
du Parlement bon c'est le jeu
parlementaire vous dites bien sûr c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne au Parlement
il faut que les Français qui regardent
cette assemblée comprennent que beaucoup
de parlementaires sont actuellement en
train de travailler en commission
notamment sur le projet de loi
immigration dans la commission des lois
donc c'est un jeu très fin de
mobilisation entre deux assemblée qui
sont les commissions et la séance et qui
se passe en même temps sur des débats
qui sont de fond qui sont extrêmement
importants donc effectivement il faut
mobiliser au bon moment et puis manuel
bonpard lui un peu moins souriant que
quelques heures avant bah il regrette
cette méthode en fait à chaque fois que
ce gouvernement est est minoritaire que
que que qu'une proposition de loi est
votée par une majorité de députés à
l'Assemblée nationale contre sa volonté
et multiplie les manœuvres dilatoires
pour l'empêcher vous avez l'impression
qu'il n'ont pas gagné à la régulière
dans l'émicycle tout à l'heure et
déposer des avendements faire traîner un
peu les débats rappeler des députés tous
les groupes le font le vôre aussi c'est
aussi le jeu non mais il faut ce qu'ils
veulent mais j'observe juste et je pense
que tout le monde tous les les les
Français qui nous écoutent le verront
comme moi que on avait l'opportunité de
voter aujourd'hui un dispositif qui
allait très concrètement changer leur
vie voilà la journée d'initiative des
parlementaires des insoumis c'est
jusqu'à minuit il y avait un moratoire
sur les mégabassines ce n'est pas adopté
et là on débat sur les services publics
merci beaucoup Elsa et pardon pour
l'interruption partie prix de yelg ce
soir nos prison déborde nouveau record
de détenus en France le chiffre a été
publié ce matin par le ministère de la
Justice
75130 personnes incarcéré on a dépassé
les limites du raisonnable oui et voilà
un chantier prioritaire pour notre garde
d' saau tout juste relaxé éric
dupontmitier a la chance d'avoir le le
meilleur budget justice de la 5e
République bah faudrait que ça ruisselle
jusqu'aux prison or c'est pas encore le
cas et c'est même la honte la France est
régulièrement condamnée par la Cour
européen des droits de l'homme on sait
dernier exemple en dat hier à Strasbourg
où le tribunal administratif a puni
l'État pour détention indigne cinq
femmes cohabitaient à la maison d'arè
Mulous dans une cellule de 12 m² je sais
pas si vous réalisez ça veut dire moins
de 3 m² par personne avec les lit
superposé la table les chaises sans
aucune intimité sans porte pour les
toilettes retenez ce chiffre une densité
carcérale moyenne en France de 123 %
jusqu'à 200 % dans certaines prisons ce
qui veut dire donc deux fois plus de
détenus accill qu'il n'y a de place pour
les loger et que fait le gouvernement
alors pour éviter que ça empire Éric
Dupont morité il mise sur la
construction c'est long c'est l 15000
places de plus promises d'ici à 2027
mais vous avez compris 15000 c'est déjà
le niveau de la surpopulation carcérale
actuelle donc on court sans cesse après
le retard et puis vous avez des élus qui
jouent pas le jeu parce que avoir une
prison près de chez soi c'est pas
forcément populaire les alternative à
l'enfermement elle se développe mais les
parquets reçoivent aussi des des
circulaires qui demandent toujours plus
de fermeté notamment s'agissant des des
trafics de drogue il y a l'option qui
consiste à mieux répartir les détenus à
les partager à les déplacer mais vous
pouvez pas non plus mélanger des gens
qui sont en détention provisoire qui
attendent leur jugement et des criminels
déjà condamnés à lourd de peine tout ce
mélange pourrait être dangereux alors il
y a bien une autre piste qui existe mais
qui n'est pas suivie par le ministre
laquelle c'est la régulation carcérale
elle est défondue notamment par une
personne qui s'appelle Dominique Simono
elle est la contrôle générale des lieux
de privation régulation carcérale ça
veut dire au-delà d'un seuil critique il
faut faire sortir des détenus si vous
voulez en faire rentrer de de nouveau ce
qui est très sensible politiquement du P
moriti il dit quoi il dit que l'opinion
française est pas prête à ça que ça
serait du carburant pour l'extrême
droite 2027 certes mais il faudra bien
revoir notre gestion de la politique
carcérale quand on a un surveillant pour
100 à 140 détenus ça peut craquer à tout
moment et tout ça à un coup pour la
collectivité pour nous tous même la Cour
des comptes s'ans plain on dépasse on
dépense 110 10 € par jour par détenu
c'est cher et vous ne ressortez pas
meilleur et réinséré quand vous êtes
enfermé dans des conditions pareilles
alors monsieur le garde des saau si vous
nous écoutez si vous nous regardez
maintenant que votre horizon judiciaire
est dégagé au boulot merci beaucoup
voilà un jolie partie prix la régulation
ça ça s'est fait pendant la pandémie
d'ailleurs beaucoup de détenus en maison
d'arrêt sont sortis ce peut être une
solution vous pensez apparemment
provisoire enfin en tout cas ce ce ce
constat il est il inspire surtout
tristesse désarrois avoir la révolte la
honte de la République disait un ancien
Président on enchaîne allez et on
termine Nicole c'est à VOUS carte
blanche je voulais revenir ce soir sur
les annonces du président Macron à
propos de la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles faites aux femmes exactement
notamment sur l'annonce qu'il a qu'il a
faite le samedi 25 novembre et cette
phrase de qu'il a prononcé la
persistance de la violence faite aux
femmes n'est pas une fatalité nous
pouvons y mettre fin nous nous allons le
faire et moi je vous avoue que j'étais
un petit peu étonnée de ce nous allons
le faire puisque justement la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
en fait c'est quand même censé être la
grande cause du quinena mais pas
celui-ci hein celui d'avant donc celui
de 2017 c'est-à-dire il y a 6 ans donc
ça l'entendre dire nous allons le faire
pour quelque chose qui est censé être
fait depuis 6 ans je me suis dit ah je
suis pas la seule à avoir des problèmes
de de procrastination même si évidemment
ce serait mentir de dire que rien n'a
été fait pendant ces 6 années des tas de
choses ont été faites le président en a
parlé notamment le fait que maintenant
on puisse appeler le 39 19 24h sur 24
augmentation du nombre de places
d'hébergement d'urgence déploiement des
bracelets antiraapprochement c'est juste
que quand on va l'étalement de ces
mesures dans le temps en France c'est
long c'est lent c'est mou on dirait un
album de Carla Bruni parce que non parce
que ça n'a pas la rythmique rapide
qu'exigerait normalement une grande
cause du quinena et ça on le voit quand
on compare notre cas avec celui de
l'Espagne parce que en Espagne par an on
des nombres 50 féminicides quand en
France on en compte 120 alors que les
Espagnols sont pas deux fois moins que
les Françaises donc autrement dit
statistiquement une Française a
quasiment deux fois plus de risque de
mourir de violence conjugale que une
Espagnole et on voyant ça on se dit
c'est pas normal sauf que quand on
regarde chez eux on se dit ah c'est pas
normal mais ça s'explique parce qu'en
Espagne la politique de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes elle est un
petit peu comme et pardonnez-moi la
comparaison leur patatas bravas vous
savez les les petites pommes de terre
avec la sauce un peu pimentée c'est
c'est puissant c'est fort et surtout
c'est servi rapidement parce que en
Espagne par exemple les bracelets
antirapprochement ils les ont pas
seulement depuis 3 ans comme chez nous
ça fait 14 ans qu'il les utilisent ou en
Espagne les 8000 places d'hébergement
ils ont pas seulement depuis l'année
dernière ils les avaient déjà il y a 4
ans alors que en France voyez la lutte
contre les violences fait aux femmes si
je devais poursuivre la la comparaison
de la patate et ben je dirais on est
plus sur un écrasé de pomme de terre une
puré c'est mou c'est tiède c'est un
petit peu là comme cette annonce qui
vient d'être faite sur la création du
kit nouveau départ pour les femmes
battues mais seulement expérimenter sur
cinq départements parce qu'il faut le
temps d'expérimenter mais sauf que là on
se dit oui mais est-ce que les
agresseurs eux nous laissent du temps
est-ce que les agresseurs ils disent oh
bah écoutez attendez pour être fairplay
je vais laisser au gouvernement le temps
de protéger mon ex-compagne avant de
retenter de la zigouiller non
malheureusement il font pas ça et c'est
pour ça que la protection des victimes
n'attend pas et c'est pour ça que des
associations réclam dès maintenant des
places d'hébergement supplémentaires
pour que notre habituelle politique du e
mieux vaut tard que jamais arrête de
ressembler à ce c'est trop tard et
malheureusement il y en a encore 120
qu'on ne reverra jamais h HM voilà et
les violences conjugales qui sont en
augmentation peut-être aussi parce que
les plaintes augmente aussi dans dans
notre pays ça vous révolte aussi
évidemment c'est c'est horrible mais au
moins un point positif c'est que
manifestement les Espagnols y arrivent
c'est vrai il y a des tribunaux mais
parce qu'il y a des tribunaux
spécialisés c'est important de le dire
et la piste est sur la table on va voir
si Éric DUP Moretti relaxéa jusque là il
a du boulot on s'arrête là merci
beaucoup merci les affranchis merci Elsa
et Merci à VOUS Dominique Bour lisez
Dominique Bour il est très prolifique
mais avec Philippe zagati il a fait ce
petit petit livre c'est la publication
d'une conférence sur la finance face aux
limites planétaires on y apprend
beaucoup de choses de monde qui se
rencontent et qui cohabite aussi très
belle soirée pour voir ou revoir cette
émission il a la chaîne Youtube d'cp
soirée documentaire qui commence
maintenant avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à
[Musique]
demain